what's got on everyone it's the true
Geordi back again a buck like a heart
attack [__]
I might actually die of a heart attack
one day if I do will you play that cuz I
that would actually make me laugh like
[__] on the other side wherever we go
who knows who knows it's gonna be fun to
find out I'm looking forward with one
day not yet though cuz the things I've
got to do like do more these videos more
podcasts and speaking of the podcasts I
want to see a massive thank you to
everyone who tuned in to the podcast who
downloaded the podcast on iTunes
we are currently number three podcast in
the UK on iTunes that is [__] mind
blood and we could still be getting
number one potentially with your help if
you haven't already got knife wound
Monica I choose Mitra you go and
download the true Joey podcast episode
one the link is in the description below
and I can't thank you enough
so even slash football the sponsors of
the podcast what a Thuggee is well and
reward some you out there so if you
don't mind click the link in the
description below download the podcast
subscribe on iTunes and leave a review
and after you've done that tweet me a
picture stop it of that review on itunes
with the hashtag true Geordie podcast
and if you do that you could win one of
five copies of FIFA 17 I mean I do too
much don't hurry well it wasn't really
me it was slash football but I I saw it
all right alright I should do some Incas
multi I'm also going to give a few
football shirts away any of the ones who
don't want fee per seventy who do win if
you don't want people something I'm
gonna say to your football shirt of your
choosing I'll even sign it for you if
you don't want us to sign it you may
think Jodi I don't want your [__]
scribbles all of them me perfectly good
shirt you couldn't alright fair enough
pours on your friend Nina your veil I
liked is that Alright so anyway that's
what you want to do if you don't make it
that but now let's talk some [__]
football on the football hangover and
we're starting with big fat Sam
Allardyce and he's big fat lies so if
you haven't heard already
big fat salamullah race has been done up
like a kipper by the undercover
reporters of the Daily Telegraph he sat
there meeting with investors who are
actually the report us and they are
asking him how you can become
third-party owners or footballers in
England slur when you sell them and
transfer them you make a [__] ton of
cash back that's a problem because in
England that's not legal the FE opposed
that you can't do that in England yet
big fat son who is employed by the FA
and the England manager it's such a good
you get around that
don't worry about and he's also a
agreeing to take on allegedly four
hundred grand to make a lot of money out
of that deal so it really pains him in a
bad way in my opinion there's no way no
[__] way he can keep his job after
this I mean it's a joke to be great on
sweetie but if he failed one let's give
big some credit he has agreed to come on
the true Johnny YouTube channel and give
his side of the story so I'm just got to
give him a ring now alright son we've
got you on the call here mate if you
could just so everyone know what the
last couple of days have been like for
you how you feeling oh God I'm not
surprised me I mean you pictures on
every TV out let everyone knows what
you've been doing behind the FAA is
bucket if that's not a will wind I don't
know what is I could tell you what me
the Daily Telegraph definitely chose you
there's no dough on that they knew
exactly who are they gonna sting [__] oh
of this time I'm not surprising me I'd
be nervous as well of me you're
wondering if you can ever going to work
again in football that is pretty
nerve-wracking how can I [__] milk
this [__] game for all it's worth and
get the most money out of it possible I
see what you were thinking this sub
don't think you went about it the way I
would have done but fair play dear
you've achieved a lot of money look I
know I've given you a hard time son but
you can't really blame as I mean your
squares to yourself and you were
disgraced everyone else oh well I'm glad
you see it that way admit yes you are a
disgrace to your family the property
hung lines and Geum when they look at
the state of you on the front of the
hookman paper but at least where you can
do now just to see yourself a little bit
of dignity what shred you've got left is
get the [__] and jump it in pal all
right thanks for the time no son I
really appreciate the call and there
I'll catch you later I mean yes big
solid a say calling into the true Jordi
YouTube channel and despite not about
being actually true are thanking for his
honesty fair play the worm a very candid
interview there I as for the management
situation what happens now we suck some
other desi probably goes and takes over
at Sun and after they sucked everybody's
we know they don't give a [__] what
you've done before you manage all play
for them they've got no scruples
whatsoever and but us for England what
do we do
Alan Pardew is the favorite [__] hell
welcome to my busted nightmare for
chrissake don't give it to Alan Pardew
now with the start of the season
I said Chelsea would not finish inside
the top phone not because they didn't
have a great set of players but because
last season the down tool so regularly I
didn't trust them to keep this good for
a full [__] season and get top four I
just can't put me faith in them and I'll
feel like to a degree I was vindicated
this weekend when they took on Arsenal
awesome all the bottle jobs also are the
ones who build the big games and this
time Chelsea bottled it the dumb tools
and this time they can't blame Josie
Mourinho he's [__] longer Oh Josie
was nasty doing who can't perform I was
seeing the real bottle jobs now because
they were pathetic in that face off
against austell three mil down before
half-time
you've got Cahill handing it over just
giving it to son Chester saw it at home
for 1 nil then hazard
ed in hazard not trucking background
better in I will be slips him in he
pluses it in the Walcott
it's 2 nil and then at the end of the
game you seem as it is all who let's be
honest he's not the fastest is he he's
not known for being a PC player storming
through the middle of the pod and candy
who was [__] raw drona last season
trottin but my Kanye you
more like an earful in western candy or
last season what's going on for him what
is what the bliz II Buster's getting him
now as well he just let him [__] run
right busting I couldn't even believe it
was the same [__] player he plays a
one-two with Sanchez and fizzle slots in
the back of the net
now let's not make no mistake about it
mas that was beautiful football from
Mosul but what a foot Chelsea this was
not they are still hot and plus it round
you and Bri the best you know the best
world-class football of all time it was
nice from Oslo but you're the master
zero and demise put a bit of roughed in
just put a little bit of effort from
hazard stops are called a little bit of
concentration from kale stops the
physical in the third goal is a bit of
grass the truck buck stops that what the
[__] is going on with Chelsea are they
going to do the same thing as he did
last season let us know in the comments
below because some people quite a few
people but tip in there for the title
six games played and there are already
eight points find Manchester City in my
opinion Chelsea already out of the title
another team who are struggling in
London is West Ham and [__] me or this
Strickland I mean that stadium nothing
in stadium is case it's the curse of the
Black Pearl
it's like [__] Pirates of the
Caribbean market they turn in then
people are just like walking around dead
everyone's dead behind the eyes when the
watching in there cuz it's [__] awful
that stadium I'm gonna call the London
Stadium the whorehouse because everyone
who goes there gets to [__] them do you
not I mean it's awful and I feel for
West Ham but then you know you've got to
think it's gonna turn around at some
point you've got Pyatt they've got
quality players eventually this has got
to stop cause right now it's as bad as
it gets in the Premier League like make
no mistake about it I'm a Newcastle man
I know bad I've watched bad for Muslim
II pastor like me last season we were
shocking and as bad as we were last
season I think West Ham in the last few
games be worse they've been worse than
we were
so this calm possibly carry on is
unbelievably bad defensively where's the
leadership where's the communication
where's the common sense when you're in
danger clear at me try to take people on
in their own third it's [__] crazy
it's actually crazy on what the hell is
going on the fans they must be sick
enough
lames this was supposed to be the season
where they kicked on they were in
Reverse they're [__] the reverse
through a brick wall the houses
collapsed on top of them people are
dying it's shocking me this is awful
so what's going to happen to West Ham
let us know in the comments below cuz
right now I could only see one thing
happening
if this doesn't change and that's the
end for southern village luckily for
West Hartnell there is a worst team in
the Premier League than them and they're
called Sunderland yes they lost 3-2 at
home to Crystal Palace I don't know how
because the petunias look Jimmy and the
four scores two goals [__] knows where
they'd be without him alright but I do
know actually Ligue 1 but they give that
two goals or like a sudden loss gives up
sex for cheesy chips made it was
pathetic I mean they didn't even want a
fight the goals were swapped yourself
but you thinking alright it's 2-2
towards the end of the game I think they
may look like a 93 94 minute and then
they get a free kick cuz Crystal Palace
but you got one man who you're gonna
mock you can walk more than [__] man
on the Crystal Palace team who do you
pick in the 94th popin minute for a
free-kick coming into the box
maybe the thirty million pound six foot
five [__] mean goal scorer Christian
benteke but no he's completely unmarked
he [__] walks in free of charge me
tink three two embarrassing
there's no doubt in my mind because
especially because Newcastle aren't in
the league and they usually pick up
obviously at least four points against
us and the rivalry allure drives them on
they haven't got that this season you
haven't got anything they're going to
[__] clue by those if do anything the
out God is demeaned appalled but even
this it's too much for him the same
sublet are getting running heated and
there were some huge wins in the Premier
League for the big boys in or Arsenal
won three nil that was massive for them
Liverpool 5-1 against Hall not surprised
and as predicted it to start the season
Liverpool are going to destroy some
teams with how the attack and Hall just
lost lambs to the [__] slaughter in
that game you know for me no more knee
really clicking in the gear lalana out
the most improved player for me under
Jurgen Klopp Jimmy Miller getting on the
scoresheet
brutal penalties for him so Liverpool
I'm feeling more confident about them
getting top four as I predicted money
and knighted had probably the biggest
win that they've had in the Premier
League since Alex Ferguson
this is this is the champions yeah let's
star city all the champions it's easy to
forget that and they smush them for one
and they look really good they needed
this so badly I said last week they're
getting worse and looked shocked and
recently but they clicked in the Kia
Papa getting on the score she
desperately needed that daily blend
getting got three assists all right you
know you've had a bad day defensively
but daily print gets three insist that
you yes let's not were terrible at the
bud
but mon united we [__] great in this
game agree did score a thunder cone for
Leicester but it was just feeble the
money United was so dominant in this
much rush for getting on the score sheet
they just look like the money needed we
thought they were going to look like
this season and if he can continue that
then maybe just maybe we might have a
title race on my hands because my jester
City they just look [__] unstoppable
me okay it's what's the point even
talking about them yeah the won 3-1
against Swansea walk its Man City doing
every week me I mean it's just happening
now isn't it the one pray that the rest
of the Premier League now [__] home
is that Kevin de Bruyne er is injured
for about a month that gives everyone a
pray that they might scrip of if you're
ever gonna slip up because make no
mistake Kevin de Bruyne
is the [__] heart beatin hots all of
that team everything goes through him
right now
if they're ever gonna split up it's now
this is when you want to play Man City
because if people can't beat them now
without Kevin de Bruyne er then it's a
right off me the Premier League's days
[__] it's gone
DOMA done now one of the big game in the
championship which was between my team
Newcastle and Aston Villa and I'll sue
me out they might no I [__] hate
Aston Villa
yeah I [__] hate the could not maybe
I don't hate them but it is personal so
I do hate them because they've relegated
us and then they just gave us for a
battle yeah I [__] hate that [__]
all right yeah so I'm really pissed off
that we didn't win this game we drew 1-1
but we were all over them you know it
seemed like we'd learned my lesson from
the previous game where we drop bite
we all over them we're mauling them heel
in the back post route in headland
crosses it in the defender kicks it into
his own net alright we're off and
running
Milas let's keep it going let's make it
count Gil gets a one-on-one opportunity
it's extreme to the keeper what'd you do
me put it in the [__] corner put it
in the right in the corner of it don't
give him the chance [__] sake we are
luck in a gold score who's just when
it's Scott was away Geils supposed to be
that one you're done on my name all
right you want to shoot me bear either
couldn't I'm getting annoyed now like
because this I'm [__] sick of the
championship I'm really starting to miss
the Premier League
we can't keep giving team's chances to
keep staying in the game once we're on
top kill them kill them all general I
mean do you army again you know he's
missing it easy to work what's the point
in the army as well you're not I mean
he's Moussa - that couldn't anyway I'm
just I'm getting frustrated because
we're dominating the game they're
massive two points drop not only was a
two points drop for us but it would've
been great and knock Villa down a peg or
two because that would have really
cemented us up there and kept them down
there and now nothing [__] nothing as
the game goes on the pressure starts
creeping up Villa stop putting the
pressure on us when we've had so much in
the game to kill them all idiot [__]
minute good friend not more in his man
cells not claiming fuchal honestly me
clean the country and they've score but
post 1-1 just a waste of [__] time I
just I'm really starting to worry that
we're not going to get out now starting
it you know the six nil I'm up the
height one
buzzing six nail will beaten QPR great
we're going to go and walk this now and
then the next few games lost in a draw
[__] hell nightmare but before I go I
better announce this week's wanker of
the week any [__] girls don't see
today it's big [__] some on a nicely
you're not only big and fat you're also
a wanker some people would say that
about me book it's merely muscle in it
yeah anywhere anywhere hope you've
enjoyed this [__] video lads don't
forget to subscribe and download my
podcasts on iTunes the link is in the
description below hit that like button
say subscribe to the true Geordie
YouTube channel and I'll say us later
[Music]